[Applause]
hello I'm a nostalgia critic guy
remember it so you don't have to I don't
know if you've noticed but Holly was
been out of ideas for a while can you
all notice but this can be a good thing
and a bad thing I did a whole editorial
about this before but that's not exactly
what I'm going to focus on here today
today I'm going to focus on a subject
matter that for the most part has still
been making a fair amount of money
the remake remakes are nothing new
literally since the dawn of cinema
remakes have been very constant
particularly when movies went from
silent to sound hell some of the same
directors came back to redirect a
timeless classic to create another
timeless classic good thing internet
blogs weren't around back then remake 10
condemned it's Pat next you want to do
an anime version with just go blue and
somehow it'll actually work so I'm
certainly not going to be a purist and
say remake should never happen some of
the best films ever made a remake
improving on the original while still
staying faithful and yet also keeping a
unique identity but needless to say this
is often difficult and very rare has a
lot of crap we've been getting Disney
once the Imagineers to bringing classic
stories to life are trying to make
classic stories out of their classic
stories out of classic stories it's
getting a little carried away so we
naturally need to ask ourselves when
should remake stop I guess the best way
to answer that and figure out when we
make sure it happens ok we all know what
Hollywood things but for the sake of
good storytelling I think we can break
it down to three factors number one the
most obvious is if it can be made better
well that can be good even
groundbreaking could still be either
dated or not fully explored some remakes
it become so classic that many people
don't even realize that remakes Scarface
is full of dollars two lies all based on
movies that existed but the remakes did
it so much better that they don't even
realize there is an original I'm
honestly surprised there aren't more
remakes of battles it's been rumor for a
while that dropped it fred was going to
get away good the original sucks
the idea of an imaginary friend taking
over your mind as an adult though is
actually kind of a cool idea
love to see this concept explored and
done a lot better than this people ask
me if I'm against the idea of Garbage
Pail Kids being remade
why the hell would happen the original
it's the worst film I have seen in my
life
the cards deserve better we make the
shit out of it hell I can't get any
worse heck is there Batman and Robin
remake in the near future it'd be nice
to see Mr Freeze done right know if he's
anything like what they're doing with
the Joker oh don't make me choose which
one is worse but okay we get the idea
it's something could be improved on
improve on it if it's broke don't fix it
make another one from scratch it's safe
to say as long as the original still
exists now Lucas another version it's
not an unwelcomed idea which breaks we
did a second reason to do a remake
expanding out a concept how this is
different than just making something
better it's taking one element of the
original idea and exploring in horror
and that a franchise that did this was a
good way and a bad way is Planet of the
Apes Tim Burton is one of the most
famous directors that coined the phrase
reimagining he said he didn't want to
improve on the original film he just
wanted to take in a different direction
it just so happened that directions up
here later another Planet of the Apes
dome would come along with a similar
thought it's rowing the planet however
this focus more on how it happened
similar to how some of the later age
films went and now it seems to be going
in a new direction that seems entirely
its own King Kong has been remade tons
of ties in the Peter Jackson version
it's still the same story but more time
is dedicated to giving Kong in our
heroine more time together creating a
stronger connections 12 monkeys was
originally a half hour sci-fi film shown
only in still pictures but that
blossomed into a motion filled
apocalyptic future that took elements
from the film and expanded on and some
of these tie-in to the number three
reason to do a remake creating a whole
new experience whether it's a different
point of view a new culture or even a
new time period as long as the identity
of the film seems unique despite it
having origins from another source it
can work magnificent 7 is famously a
remake of Seven Samurai both have the
same plot but I said in different time
periods and location
films like the rain birdcage and the
departed are all remakes of foreign
classics telling these great stories in
different cultures shows both the
differences and the similarities between
the two making it interesting what they
have to change now what they have to
keep the same okay so we have three
reasons when remakes should be done I
guess when they shouldn't be done is the
opposite reasons if a remake needs to
stand out then logically the first sign
not to do a remake is when people can't
separate it from the original I get a
feeling a lot of the Ghostbusters reboot
controversy yeah I'm still point
controversy in quotes it's because the
original was so unique and one-of-a-kind
that no one could separate it if it was
a sequel and they have had a better shot
or even a spin-off but when people hear
the word reboot it's like saying now
this is what you're going to think of
when you hear ghostbusters even though
everyone will clearly think of this
first a lot of Universal monster movies
are trying to get remade and despite
most of them being based on classic
works it's hard to not think of Karloff
as Frankenstein or Lugosi as Dracula or
Chaney as the Wolfman and a great
American box office neither can anyone
else
oddly enough the ones that seemed the
most ridiculous like the mummy would
Brendan Fraser at least when in such a
different direction that we can kind of
say that was uniquely their own thing
but how would anyone going to say yeah
Johnny Depp that's the first thing I
think of when I hear Willy Wonka Geno
some will be leave such an impact that
it makes it harder to do a version that
can survive on its own without
constantly coming back to the original
if you don't have something super good
or incredibly unique in mind when
remaking an icon you're not going to be
the definitive version but they can also
backfire the other way like the number
two reason not to do a remake we just do
the exact same thing you name the beast
had this bad so many of the lines
visuals and songs were all seen before
and done better in the animated version
it was so unique and aspiring when they
first did it so why would we want to see
non singers and non expressive actors do
the same thing Gus Van Sant tried a very
strange experiment with the movie psycho
doing a shot-for-shot rien
Ackman that's literally doing the exact
same thing except now all the freshness
is sucked out of it and we can notice
the flaws even more
what would this accomplish Rob Zombie's
remake of Halloween at first looked like
it was going to be something different
diving deeper into Mike Myers childhood
and devoting more time to him but even
that's done pretty generically and when
that's passed it's just the same story
of Halloween again except with no real
surprises but what's even worse than
doing the exact same thing is the number
of three reason not to do a remake doing
less then her is one of the biggest
films to exist in every meaning of the
word the stunts the story the sets it is
the definition of epic so the idea of
seeing a CGI remake we're so much less
is obviously not there it seems
degrading Maya marinelle Street is known
for its creative depths and original
ideas but with the remake is either
repeated or scaled-down even the makeup
just looks like an unimaginative rehash
it's not different it's not unique it's
just the same thing except so much less
it's a guy who controls dreams that's
burned alive you can do something cooler
with this design the original wicker man
was a surreal and bizarre experience and
while the remake is certainly bizarre
and entertaining and how bad the choices
they made are so much of the creative
environment is lost resulting in what
most people can agree is a god-awful
movie sometimes the opposite can be true
too when you take too much out and
replace it with too much explanation The
Shining and Alice in Wonderland remakes
go way overboard and trying to make a
super detailed and complicated story but
that's not what we loved about the
originals we didn't know what everything
meant we didn't need a reason for all
the strange visuals
that's what was part of making it such a
unique experience by trying to add more
explanation it took away the imagination
they say the devil is in the detail in
this situation they're definitely right
whether for better or worse all of these
elements represent the most
horton thing in making a remake it's
hard it's passion its reason for being
everything that almost can't be
explained that that we makes even the
most different ones managed to capture
the heart of the original source
material whether they improve on it or
taking it a different direction the
connection is always there and the worse
remakes always don't capture it
they either try too hard not hard enough
or just focus on the wrong thing in a
time we're very little as original it's
hard to figure out what's going to
capture the heart of something and what
isn't I never would have imagined an
Evil Dead remake would be of any worth
who the hell would a thought of musical
of a b-movie which surprisingly work
what we do know is a lot more remakes or
coming whether we want them to or not
some surprises with how good they are
some surprises without bad they are but
the ones we'll remember the most
surprisingly don't give us something old
they always give us something uniquely
[Music]
I thought it smells good a guy remember
so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out and if you're driving
on the road and you see some fire men
going up and down the street carrying a
boot and you give money you probably got
one of these this is MDA the muscular
dystrophy association really diagnosis
highly specialized care and access to
promising clinical trials health ensure
the best possible outcomes for
individuals and families facing muscular
dystrophy as well as ALS and any other
related muscle diseases their MDA care
centers offer families best-in-class
comprehensive care from a wide variety
of health care specialists at one
location on the same day MDA has more
than 150 care centers across the United
States and in Puerto Rico located at top
hospital and health care facilities
individuals can see knowledgeable health
care specialists from a variety of
backgrounds all at one location the MDA
family care specialist is a center
figure at the center visits if you go to
their site and especially their YouTube
page with so many inspiring videos you
too can see how you can make a huge
difference click on the link give a
watch and see what you can do to help
cure this forever
[Music]
you